bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti come
sono video sono pa vj e prima di
cominciare questo video volevo
annunciarvi che ho lanciato il
merchandising online delle magliette
adesso potete prenderli anche voi le
trovate in descrizione e con il codice
sconto pietro puzza potete avere il 15
per cento di sconto sui vostri ordini
è una cosa limitata ma per il lancio del
merchandising online quindi se volete
accaparrarvelo accaparrate vela pace un
effetto strano è perché ciò il green
screen attivo in realtà e verde qui e
verde però non si vede perché ciò faccio
youtuber per passione
direi che possiamo cominciare ragazzi
siamo dannati su è più il soldato
semplice perché nella live dove l'ho
aperto il secondo canale che abbiamo
fatto 200 mila iscritti di un giorno
iscrivetevi al secondo canale ho trovato
è più hills di nuovo divertente perché
c'erano molte cose nuove stranamente che
mi ha sorpreso volta allora ho detto
vabbè dai possiamo fare dei nuovi
tentativi e voglio assolutamente farli
sappiate ragazzi che uscirà quindi ogni
domenica di nuovo è previsto un
pochettino di tempo quindi non perdetevi
gli episodi
ripartiamo con il maestro del videogioco
su internet
mamma mia ragazzi oltre o ultimate
iniziamo con un po altro che ci
riscaldiamo è da tempo che lo faccio
molto
thanks for traini prego purtroppo per
chi non lo conoscesse per chi stesse
guardando questo gioco per la prima
volta e siete veramente fuori dal mondo
contro rilanciare le palle e farle
entrare nella casa della luce scritto
win tipo come faccio io
tre palle non era esattamente win ma
guarda se non finisci chi ti ammazzo per
favore ti prego fammi fare una bella
figura che il primo livello dopo una
vita che faccio fammi fare bella figura
fame l'affare stabilirà se grasse dopo
si sgancia un po di soldi tv altro sono
così felice tra il punto molto bravo
sono molto bravo nel centro di buchi non
pensavo freddy mercuri poco ma cos'è
vabbè ma perché spiegano e le corone dei
queen
devi riuscire a saltare si cosi si no
we are the champions grazie grazie a
tutti
guarda troppo p non so cosa voglia dire
vilas world trovo è un altro tipo di
livello che vi spiego bisogna far fuori
gas sono stato bravissimo e non so
neanche come devo far fuori la gente va
bene allora fai quello che vuoi mi hai
anche creato un pene grazie
devo far fuori la gente senza che senza
finire le spade quindi devo finire spade
che tutti sono morti una cosa molto
difficile fare però attenzione
me ne manca un po lezioso bene cosa sta
facendo quello tutto a destra io non
vorrei commentare questa cosa però non
fa niente boltro epica colori fare tifo
anche l'epic perché sicuramente merita
guardali co e vinco immediatamente
sono in tre io reble cross non sempre
stato un fenomeno non solo da
rimorchiare faccio schifo pro né contro
me la cavo e forse era meglio il
contrario o il 99 per cento in prossimo
spiegare questo sarà un po difficile il
99 per cento imposti con sono livelli
che al 99 per cento tu non vuoi vincere
perché proprio delle cose che non sono
molto difficili da superare ma che io
sono talmente skillato tutto giocano
rimorchiato per anni ragazzi ci sarà un
motivo
io posso farcela anche se il gioco è
incredibilmente difficile sono molto a
dimenticavo se arrivi al traguardo ma
sei morto normale ma edizione alla vita
è stato difficilissimo non ce la posso
fare ragazzi me lo sento io che
schiaccia a maledizione bravo bravo sono
cattivo
no no mi ha investito una bici mentre
volta guarda un ciclo
se non stai calmo orco demoni va bene è
molto difficile il suo livello ma vi
assicuro che se in uk mi fa da scudo
bravo così lo vogliono sacrificati per
tuo padre come sta andando avanti come
sta andando avanti aiuto cos'è ma dai
sai che difficilissimo arriva un niente
dalla fine muoio porca vacca che
l'effetto perfetto buona buona ma robot
non scherzavo mi ha investito la
medicina ora che ascom qua fino a domani
giuro ti prego no niente a nessuno non è
vero
ai ragazzi un macello perfetto da milo
spingerla melo scritta da mio fin troppo
speed ragazzi e divertenti segnale
bellissimo è cambiato un backup tua
sorella suo livello fra gli dicevo è
cambiato molto perché finalmente c'è
roba divertente
sono contento che sia migliorato così
tanto ha vinto la mia gamba varrà
qualcosa
mamma mia sono a posto scherzavo allora
ok a posto per luke via via via via via
via scano scanna schema bravo ma anche
solo nazione ce l'ha fatta
no ci credono no ragazzi di l'arpione
finale mi frega sempre sempre è troppo
difficile ragazzi ve lo giuro
ce l'ho fatta possiamo portare
qualcos'altro dove stavo scherzando mi
piace non mi piace mi piace
ok ok ok ok ok che il perfetto perfetto
vai vai vai vai chi no
bravo allora è fatta devi solo no è
fatta devi solo non beccare quello in
testa se non muori
ti prego così cosmi conviene scendere
dalla bici e trascinarmi scende dalla
bici mi trascino con un braccio
me ne frega niente prego però scendi per
favore te lo chiedo accendi da davanti
scendi da davanti dalla bici perfetto
trascinati non è difficile bravo di
trascinarti zero cioè fidati devi
trascinarti il braccio che ti serve ti
prego dall abc sta per investire la vice
di stabilirsi
ok trascinati con un braccino bravo
bravo
[Musica]
un'ora e mezza di questo livello ce l'ho
fatta
e stato divertente per voi si segue i
troppi storico a ok devo mamma mia non
ho mai capito ma sono tutti i personaggi
di prestigio justin bieber tra l'altro
justin bieber i non si sono mai ma ai
tempi era orco demonio sono riuscite a
morire in un livello in cui non si può
morire fantastico justin bieber e ai
tempi di happy wizz air ha preso
negativamente a fabiano importa poi se
abbiamo fatto un 99 per cento impostino
altre a fare un 99,99999 per cento in
posti come cosa succede
scegliamo steve welcome to my first love
is really sheet 9 che lagna guarda che
se non vinco lei ho bisogno valori prima
ci ha messo un'ora e mezzo a questo che
era teoricamente più difficile promesso
di meno fammi vedere come è possibile
che che movimento delle già cosa ho
fatto qua cosa ho fatto l'uno so
neanch'io prova bene arriviamo al
capostipite di livelli si chiama rock
swing rock swing si fanno con è di lui è
lì ragazzi è il ragazzo del segway
praticamente tutti attacchi alle corde
non quello che pensa te devi fare tipo
tarzan devi arrivare da una corda
all'altra troppo avanti
e invece va bene lo stesso perché era
andato esattamente dove dovevo andare di
attaccare una corda all'alta arriva alla
fine del livello molto belli rock swing
è tra i miei sono trame livelli
preferiti in assoluto
soprattutto perché sono bravo però
psichico perché ninjawords crisi questo
è molto bello
devi lanciare delle spade freezer le per
coprirti una l'ho fatta c'è l'ha fatta
ho vinto un cervello che però mi è
caduto allora prendo le bombe ho vinto
la bomba forse era meglio non vincere
niente però dettagli
benvenuta l'ascensore per lo spazio
clicca per andare clicco emozionante
in che senso io rimango qua sono o che
bello dove stiamo andando lì preciso non
sto capendo chi vi ha chiesto di
portarmi nello spazio non c'ho voglia di
stare una scusa c'è adesso mi sputa gli
ufo ma quanto il quotato l'alieno
adesso passeremo la luna come minio e
poi ci sono gli scritti di fa vj dopo
però eccola la luna successo leggo la
scritta buona visita grazie strada da
allora ecco quella è la terra o mio dio
come fatta fuori su facebook
lo porta a fare con effetto ferino 8 il
flip forum dip
quindi per me va bene facciamo un patto
philippe per i vip sono un vip indiana
jones in bossi in bossi ball ho fatto
vivere ci credo motivo
tanto poi c'è scritto in bossi folds i
padroni rimborsi voi questo rimborsi
voler l'ip ragazzi per me un'emozione
riportarvi questo gioco perché comunque
è sempre stato per me tutto forse la
serie più di successo di tutto il mio
canale senza forze quindi 5 milioni di
iscritti o fatti così è
l'avevo interrotto perché era diventato
un po tutto il noto simile invece adesso
hanno aggiunto cose nuove la cosa mi
sono veramente contento di questo quindi
vedrete ogni domenica almeno per un po
poi vediamo inventerete finalmente degli
episodi di aping quindi iscrivetevi al
canale attivate la campanella per
ricevere le notifiche sono gli arrivano
le notifiche iscrivetevi anche il
secondo canale vi ricordo che il
merchandising delle magliette lo trovate
in descrizione e noi come sempre ci
vediamo ora un prossimo vito bella
ragazzi
[Musica]